hi I'm Trixie Mattel and I'm Katya and
today we're gonna be cutting these
people's throats hair I have an
advantage here because I went to a
beauty school mama I made an art school
shut you but listen to get into this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
3/4 through beauty school I had to drop
out to go do drag race so now for the
rest of my life I got to hear that
[ __ ] song and grease
what as thumb why do you like me free
sliding what do you think high school
dropout you know you could play Harry
Potter in a porn oh my god style trend
alert wire-rimmed glasses [ __ ] yeah oh
my god oh you have actually stunning
here ok how do you spell your names
Kye you know I've had not one not two
fifteen boyfriends in pop so I'm gonna
get myself a bang trim which is this is
a very bad idea
you look like a baby but you have gray
hair are you the intimate button um not
that I know of yet but dole I are you a
[ __ ] Benjamin Button called you for
real 24 Grey's at 24 [ __ ] you are a
stud oh I know what you do put them so
we're gonna take three locks of our hair
and sell them online in beauty school
they taught us you don't work in the
beauty industry you work in the
self-esteem in this area so how do you
feel Rashad I feel very good I see I'm
gonna take it from the bottom are you
okay with that yeah a party take over
the bottom cells like Nia Long Beach
Bryan a tease
honey do you know I did when I got on
drag race the next day I wanted to beat
you schools packed up everything and
left and didn't tell anyone here could
it is stressful like it's extremely
difficult she's an idiot it may be
caused by an idiot climber my makeup is
lazy no you make it look like too easy
oh I just like shaving heads do you know
what I cut my own hair
I'm Neil and Neil on the floor in a
hotel I just love America I deerhead it
take a piece on I dare you because you
did this Nigeria during that guy Russell
I would grow up my dad's a crime master
I would waste you I guess you wasted
your life to waste mine to have a
boyfriend me no you know that my
adherence my commitment to beauty is so
severe that are not the heart to [ __ ] up
your beautiful hair do you know that
thank you
you need to wake up tomorrow and get on
your yeah you're gross dirty knees day
to God or whomever yeah thank you
Yahweh or or or whatever to for this
gorgeous head of hair which is not
thinning anytime soon are you I mean and
that hairline is gonna stay put thank
you you're first who do you think is
prettier near Katya a gentle reminder
that there is only one correct answer to
the centaurum I know there's a [ __ ]
mechanical raisin issue can we take this
off you I feel like you are a victim of
a crime
oh my god oh man it's starting again
they only happen in the salon now Kahn
when you go to a salon what kind of
service did you like something really
like in and out did you want something
really luxuriously rub your hands at
[ __ ] you know usually it's the in and
out in and out options yeah you really
know me so I want like something super
silky and straight but I still really
bouncy curling voluminous you know when
I was little Kyle at a mullet and asked
my mom why shouldn't cut it and she said
she'd have the heart to so she just let
part of the girl because she wanted to
come here to be like virgin for miles
baby
so [ __ ] I had like like your old [ __ ]
animation lower back rat tail running
through the woods of Wisconsin like a
[ __ ] raccoon Melissa Joan Hart follow
me on Twitter why do you think so Kyle
oh yeah I'm serious I why do I she
follow [ __ ] well I saw her on the
Hollywood medium she's very Christian so
I thought why does she care about me oh
I thought Hollywood medium honey and
Hollywood I'm a 4x honey I'm fully
quitting dragon fighting the nearest
great clips and just getting my life so
with you nice what I did here was we
played it safe but we also did it dirty
we had a moment we shared some common
goals we learned a few things about each
other and we just created a priceless
piece of art that we will now stall on
the internet for probably like 300 bucks
yeah oh yeah it wears it it's right on
your head oh yeah oh it's very nice no I
love that you lied to me no I love it I
love it thank you so much no she's not
my the Trixie conscious show debuts on
November 15th on Vice land if you like
the homeless haircuts and trips to
Hoboken join us on November 15th on Vice
land yes all right that's it thank you
goodbye
[Music]